[Applause]
you're watching the project welcome back
Australia's favorite maths teacher
absolute favorite Eddie Wu is teaming up
with gaming Guru Steph Ben Dixon in a
new four-part series it's called
ultimate classroom it's on 10 featuring
18 of the country's brightest high
school students this challenge is going
to involve engineering Force vectors and
some light mountaineering you're going
to need to construct a bridge strong
enough to safely transport a vehicle
from one side to the other
time's gonna go quick guys
and the good news is that Eddie joins us
right now
the only thing you do is fun tell us
about this competition
well each episode teams go head to head
completing challenges based on science
technology engineering and math so as
you saw Building Bridges other things
like programming drones or even
deciphering radio waves and then each
team is scored on how well they
self-solve the problem and how creative
their Solutions are Eddie this question
is triggering for me
um because I want to know how the teams
are selected and please tell me it's not
like we all you know I'll have Scotty
well no one ever chose me basically you
know how you get to choose one for the
basketball team then you'd choose the
other until there was only me left
standing I don't think it'd be any
spoilers to say that I'd be with you as
the second last person or last person
being selected on a sporting team but
for this you know obviously a lot of
kids would love to be on TV but we were
really interested in finding people who
were passionate about stem and also who
could think critically Under Pressure so
as part of the casting process we
actually had the finalists complete a
challenge in games to see how well they
would bring together multiple
perspectives and create a cohesive plan
for action so that's why the teams you
see on the episodes are that good well
you talk about the pressure Eddie the
student's work is judged by a
Specialists from the Defense Force is my
understanding so just how hard are these
challenges
well it is called the ultimate classroom
so every challenge is about taking
things to the next level I'll tell you
one of my favorites was where teams had
to navigate an obstacle course but they
couldn't see the course all they had
were sonar readings like from a
submarine and they had to use that to
find their way so obviously very very
tough but it was great seeing the teams
rise to the challenge Eddie be honest I
mean are these the smartest kids in the
room
uh they're outstanding I mean someone
wise said to me if you are the smartest
person in the room you're in the wrong
room and these kids definitely gave me a
run for my money I loved learning
alongside them well I hope that there
might not be an age limit next time
Eddie because I'd love to have a crack
at some of these challenges ultimate
classroom is Sundays at 6 30 on 10 shake
and 10 play thank you so much for
joining us any word my pleasure thanks
everyone